[Music]
[Applause]
scottie pippins released his own bourbon
it's called digits
with uh acclaimed napa winemaker and
distiller dave finney of
savage and cook he also has a popcorn
snack coming out called husk
has a memoir called unguarded that's
coming out later on this fall
he's uh he's a mogul he's scottie pippen
on the program
scotty how are you i'm great dan it's a
pleasure to be here with you
uh once i'm trying to think the last
time we spoke
um probably uh six years ago
you're making some headlines here scotty
dan i'm always making headlines i need
to keep my mouth closed
is there anything that you want to
clarify put in context
from the gq article um
not really i mean i think with the kevin
durant thing i think
that uh people may not have understood
the question
asking me you know had he surpassed
lebron james
um from a standpoint of looking at it at
basketball
and what lebron james have been able to
do from carrying
a team uh i don't think kevin durant
is at a position where i can say that he
surpassed lebron james
yeah and you're just being an analyst
here looking at this
it it didn't feel personal but it felt
like kevin
took it personally is that how you kind
of assess that
yeah and that's kind of how kevin takes
anything
unless you're praising him and pushing
him up uh
and i wasn't trying to um
in any way belittle him uh i think he's
a very talented player
uh he's shown that by you know his mvp
he has two finals mvps but still
um the question that i answered was
based on him and lebron's conversion
how would you guard him and how
different would that be in guarding
lebron
well dana i'm gonna be honest the way i
played the game
they would have to come back in my era
and play uh
i can't play in today's era this is uh
this is a non-touch game
this is a shooter's game where they're
not any contact
uh i played in an area where the game
was physical
and you had to um
physically be ready for that type of
challenge
night in and night out it wasn't a game
where you knew you were going to get
open shots or you weren't going to get
knocked to the floor
um so i asked me how i would guard those
guys would be difficult
for me if i'm looking at today's rules
if you were if durant was playing by
1995 rules
against you i mean it would be a totally
different game for him
uh he wouldn't be the same player that
he is today
uh his ball handling would be limited
because you could get into a player's
body but
not just durant i mean every player i
mean the
game had more physical quality to it
where you could
pretty much guard a player from 94 feet
and use your defensive skills to try to
take him out of
the game and that's not where today's
game
is although lebron could play in
1995 the physicality probably wouldn't
affect him as much i'm guessing
yeah i mean i'm not saying kevin durant
couldn't play i'm just saying he would
not be that type of score
now on the other hand lebron james
doesn't look to
be a uh horrific score when he plays the
game he plays the game
in a whole different mindset he utilizes
teammates he
he he looks to be a distributor more so
than a score but he's a very effective
scorer
because of his size and his strength do
you think lebron
would have made the nets better that
they would have gotten in
they would have they'd still be playing
i can't say that by saying
yes okay but um it would have been a
whole different look had lebron been on
the court
uh he's more of a distributor kevin
durant
is a scorer so you're going to be
looking at a guy that's going to be
playing more for triple doubles
instead of trying to score 40 or 50.
i'll say that um help me understand
the gq article where you talked about
the 1994 playoff game
when you refused to go back in the game
and phil set up the play for tony cucoch
well i mean there's not much to be said
if you go back and look at
when scottie pippen entered the bulls
and when tony kuch
kenneth and who deserved the last shot
of the game
no no i understand that scotty i'm just
going by what you said you said
you need to read between the fine lines
and then you go on to say
it was a racial move to give him tony
cucoch a ride
so i mean if you knew that scottie
pippen had been with the bulls from 87
battle through the pistons and every
other team
that we had to get to those three
championships
wouldn't you give scottie pippen one
opportunity to get a last second shot
without michael jordan like one year
without my majority
can i get one shot like i'm doing all
the dirty work
but all of that i understand from the
basketball standpoint but when you say a
racial move
well why would why would tony who was a
rookie get the last second shot
and you put me up for violence that's
what i mean racial
like that was scottie pippen's team but
on pace to be a mvp that year right
yeah okay well why would you put him in
a position
not to be successful why wouldn't you
put him in a position
to succeed michael jordan is not there
so who's next in line for you
but if you talk to phil about this
because by saying a racial move
then you're you're calling phil a racist
i don't got a problem with that do you
think phil
was or is oh yeah i mean do you remember
phil jackson left the lakers went wrote
a book on kobe bryant and then came back
and coached
him i mean who would do that
you named someone in professional sports
that would do that
you know i think he tried to expose
kobe in a way
that he shouldn't have you're the head
coach and you're the guy that sits in
the locker room
and tells the players this is a circle
and everything stays within the circle
because that's what team is about
but you as the head coach open it up
and now you go out and you try to
belittle at that time probably one of
the greatest players
in the game well it feels like
he's disloyal i don't know if that makes
him
a racist well that's
your way of putting it out
and i have my way i was in the locker
room with him i was in practice since
waiting
uh you're looking for him afar yeah and
and look that's why i wanted to have you
on
but i go back and phil designed a play
for steve kerr
when mike was there and mike mike didn't
have a problem with that did he
oh i don't want to you're not you're not
setting me up to answer the right
question what do you mean phil
set up a play for steve or he didn't set
that play for seeker he said that player
for michael george
i thought in the huddle mike says i'm
going to throw you the ball you'll be
opening
that the felon that and phil had nothing
to do with that
and you don't want to get this show
started because it'll take us a long
time
do you know all those cameras that's
sitting in that huddle who they was
working for
the nba you know who michael was
speaking to when he said that right
that was that was planned
that was speaking to the to the camera
that wasn't
speaking out of what we're gonna have to
do what the play is going to be
that was speaking to the camera had john
had uh john stockton not came down trust
me
but that was building his own
documentary
because he knew he was controlling the
cameras
you understand english yeah okay so
all those cameras that was working were
working basically
for michael jordan
not for the chicago bulls but they were
building
the come fly with me the air jordan
videos
that's what it was if
that was not naturally spoken okay
that was rehearsed okay uh did you guys
understand that he was doing a
documentary that last year
we understood from phil jackson that the
nba
wanted to do some behind-the-scenes
footage
for the team documentary
that's what we was understood that's
what we were sold
but that wouldn't hide
uh you you just you uh phased out a
little bit there with your connection so
yeah yeah i wasn't pausing yeah i wasn't
pausing because i didn't understand what
you were saying just
wanted to let you know but you feel like
like there's anger
with you or clarification or so i don't
know i'm trying to get a feeling it's
more
i think it's more clarification
because you had a great career i'm not
angry
angry at all yes i've had a great career
a
wonderful time um in chicago
and uh it is what it is but i think
there needs to be some clarification you
know
about a lot of things that happened
whether it was in the documentary or
through the gq
ad that i spoke on i i
i didn't know you know how you were
portrayed in the in the documentary
and obviously it was slanted but i just
if everybody knew you signed a bad
contract did it need to be brought up
that you've signed a bad con like i
don't know it felt like it was probably
well i
i think my biggest thing with the
documentary was um
that michael who didn't play in 94
who was selling a video based on the
last dance
was something that he sort of tried to
pull out
to show
that our winning was all about me
and this is what everybody else did when
i uh wasn't around
because he didn't hate that in his
documentary i mean he wasn't on the team
yeah you know and if anything if you're
gonna
show that you call feel why didn't you
show
that you called field to bad for me i
mean i'm
probably was the only man standing um
who had been there with him back in the
early 80s
but yet he comes back
the next year because
it was getting good we weren't fading
away
have you talked to michael since the
documentary
no do you want
not not really talk we kind of talked
during it a little bit but not
no do you want to
no i mean i think we both moved on in
our life there's nothing to be uh
holding on to that went on 20 plus years
ago
what did you think there's nothing for
us to talk about that i mean we could
talk about our life and our families and
our
golf game or something but it's no we
got to go back and clarify nothing
happened in the
90s what did you think when he said he
was going to go play baseball
um i didn't really think about it i was
really uh
focused on my own craft at that time but
i thought
it was a big decision though yeah it was
it was a big decision
but it was a it's a selfish decision but
it was kind of uh who michael jordan was
and that's was a guy that kind of
believed that he can do anything on his
own
the relationship was just a we're
teammates and that was
about it i mean yeah pretty much i mean
we were
excellent teammates i mean i think we
try to make more out of it sometimes the
way it really was
but you know we were great court
teammates who had a very good
understanding
of each other and what it took to win
talking to scottie pippen he has a new
bourbon out digits
uh that's been in the works for a while
how did you come up with this
idea i see um you know i've been a
little boozer for quite a while
i think winning here in chicago and
spend a lot of cold
winters here so i i used to be a a bit
of um
a crown raw drinker and during a
pandemic
when me and my business partner just
kind of um
sitting around talking and he said hey
you should create your own bourbon
and he said i got an idea
and he had been in the wine business for
quite some time so he had of um
a little bit of confidence that he could
um i guess get through the doors and
into savage and cook which is dave
phoenix uh company
what's next
well there's a few things i've got my
hus popcorn which is so super food and
um it's uh something that we're looking
forward to launching here in the next
couple weeks
what's in this book that's coming out in
the fall
uh just pretty much
about my career you know starting up
growing up in a small town hamburg
arkansas and
you know advancing on to central organs
all right just kind of um you know
my life and what channels and all that i
went through trying to get into the nba
and you know what it was like playing
with michael and
field playing for the bulls organization
i kind of believe there's going to be
something in here that's going to get
you in trouble scotty i'm like
right there's got to be something that's
coming out in this book right
dan i don't i don't get i don't get in
trouble
i try to keep trouble trouble may find
you scotty i don't know
yeah every time i open my mouth somehow
it seems to try to
drive me down a troubled path but i'm
really not trying to uh
mislead anybody or did you
did you ever play jordan one-on-one in
practice
oh no no how would that have gone
it would have been interesting uh he had
his
moments where he was at a high and i had
my moments in my career without
i was at a high so uh it would have been
an interesting matchup but
in my era i never really believed in
one-on-one
and that's kind of where the game has
evolved into
today by the way
on that draft night when you and old and
polyneice were traded for one another
yes i'm i'm sitting right there
and you guys had hats on so you have
your seattle supersonics hat on
and then all of a sudden you hear uh and
a trade to announce
the bulls and supersonics are swapping
first round pick so you and olden
polonies
changed hats right there in front of us
i mean it was
it was it was wild to see that you ever
wonder what your career would have been
like
if you weren't traded
i mean i would have some pretty good
teammates especially if we were still
landing
sean kemp gary payton uh you know it is
a team that we played in the finals
so that sort of fit
that would have been a pretty good team
to to join that would have been fun to
go against mike with that seattle team
probably been a lot of fun yeah
i don't know if you would have made it
that far
if you know what i mean well
see there you go you're stirring it up
again
i'm just saying
[Laughter]
mike needed you he didn't win without
you right
that's what they tell me
well good luck with the bourbon it's
called digits and uh
the uh popcorn snack called husk and
then
the book i'll probably be talking to you
in the fall because i'm sure there's
something in this book
unguarded scotty but i appreciate it
thank you hey thanks for joining us and
i appreciate you giving me the uh
opportunity to ask you to put this in
context and uh you're certainly not
afraid that's
uh that's for sure but thank you scotty
all right thank you guys
that's uh scottie pippen let's take a
break we'll uh
break that down